the people that are being persecuted by
the Democrats by The Establishment
they're not in a position to say okay
we're gonna go ahead and chill things
out and the reason is because all of the
things that they're accused of are all
things that are legal like they they
fabricate stuff the guy that from
Infowars that's going to go to jail
he was speaking like
was talking to people right and these
aren't it wasn't inside and it is such
these are such tortured accusations and
they have to be stretched and twisted so
much to make them fit it's ridiculous
and because of that it has to be the the
people that are in the position of power
saying okay we're going to stop using
our power because the people that are
not in positions of Power are not in any
position to say we're going to stop
escalating because they're not the ones
escalating exactly Tim you brought it up
Fanny Williams actually refused to
indict these people